with league of legends mid-season
invitational done and dusted there's
just too much to ignore a silent busan
auditorium a trophy wheeled out in a
practice room a new msi world record
artificial ping a t1 and faker that came
so close
and then faltered
and a contentious interview response
from a coach
i just hope that when worlds rolls
around we get a rematch of this msi
grand finals
[Music]
alright before we get into the video
we've got a new series launching this
thursday called worth and it's about the
stories in esports worth telling our
first episode will be about the greatest
stand-in performance in esports history
keep your eyes peeled for that don't
miss it let's get into the video msi was
great this year but in a lot of ways it
was pretty unusual for one because of
covid related restrictions set by the
chinese government lpl spring winners
royal never give up were forced to play
remotely that meant riot had to
artificially create ping for the other
teams in the tournament in order to
compensate and when there were issues
with that system three of rng's group
stage matches had to be replayed but
even more than that it felt like this
msi was a chance for t1 to truly prove
their ability if you're not familiar
with the recent news on t1 they just
came off a title-winning split where
they went perfect in match score in the
incredibly competitive lck excitingly
the faker and four zoomers composition
of the team looked as if it was becoming
even stronger and i really don't think
faker needs an introduction at this
point but if you want to catch up on
what he's been doing recently you can
check out the story of t1 law which we
released recently and was written by
yours truly or check out the don't at me
about the perfect season that dany did
it was awesome so this msi represented a
valuable opportunity for an
internationally inexperienced roster
besides baker of course to test
themselves against the world's best and
listen heading into this tournament
you'd be forgiven for believing that t1
pretty much had this thing in the bag
and part of the reason for that is that
the lpl's representative royal never
give up is not exactly the team that
everybody thought would be here t1 on
the other hand has been a major story
and they've shown incredibly focused and
oppressive early game play that's not by
accident riot have literally changed the
game in a recent patch they call the
champion durability update to
intentionally move away from champions
being able to instantly blow up other
champions so it's something even the
devs are thinking about rng were simply
not that kind of early game focused team
they outlasted opponents and finished
the game but one thing that t1 and rng
do both have in common are their veteran
mid laners rng's seasoned mid laner
xiaohu won msi last year but he was
playing a completely different position
see xiaohu has been around for a while
he made his pro debut in season 5 at age
17. last year it was thought that the
mid lane pool and the lpl was just too
deep for him to keep swimming around
while wearing i assume an old man
bathing suit an inflatable scuttle crab
pool toy he's 24. i don't know why i'm
leaning really hard into the old man
thing but anyways he had to switch to
top lane last year and he did a very
good job while adapting his playstyle to
be a little bit more conservative and
supportive than he had in the past
though we still saw some of those
flashes of brilliance that had made him
such a mechanically exciting mid laner
but in 2022 the team acquired bim the
top laner who had gone to world's 2020
grand finals with sooning
suddenly xiaohu was back in the mid lane
and so in grand finals at msi 2022 who
else does xiaohu see across from him but
another journeyman mid and a living
symbol of korea's esports greatness
faker like i said these two teams play
pretty differently so when they met in
the grand finals at msi it wasn't only
this international clash with old man
mids on both sides but also potentially
a verdict on their two styles ben has
been criticized for perceived
inconsistency in the past but he was
locked in this tournament and a big key
to that was gwen a champion that is
frankly kind of balanced around having a
weaker early game before she really
comes online later so t1 and rng meet in
the grand finals and in game one bin
absolutely pops off on gwen going 13-0
and three
keep that in mind then in game two we
get this ridiculous baron play that
helps seal the game for t1 a jinx and a
time kench versus a team of baron you've
seen this before the charm flashed away
by yuma yushi faker looking to get in
from the back of the pit frozen tomb
available for him rng
t1
and baker finds
will not go quietly into the night form
is temporary baker is forever this was a
back and forth series and in game four
we got to see faker on leblanc
at msi yeah it's awesome and it's a
champion he's known for uh which i think
is so interesting to watch looking for
faker now trying to get underneath the
tower needs to dodge away from the other
foster charm the root he dodges
perfectly oh faker you beautiful man
escapes the three man died
what was that
so
after t1 brings rng to a game five rng
rightly bans the champion that got them
there leblanc but bin's gwen did not get
the same respect it went unbanned but
not only that after it was first picked
in game 5 t1 literally picked jace into
it and that's a pretty rough matchup for
zeus to have to navigate then t1 blind
picked an ari wukong mid-jungle duo
which was immediately counter-picked
they picked up jin for gumiyushi and
karia locked in yumi at the end of the
draft also ari jin and jace all rely
heavily on projectiles now gwen's
hallowed missed ability makes her
invulnerable to projectiles so
not a great pick overall right it's a
draft that on paper looks less than
ideal but in game things were even worse
but yeah you just start acceleration
gate because then when finn goes forward
you can't get on
a carrier cannot jump back onto guma
yushi the chase is on the ignite is
ticking and ming will claim first blood
maybe it's a stretch to say that this
draft lost them the game immediately but
it certainly didn't help them and rng
were uncharacteristically able to take
control of the early game and just
dominate the rest of it xiaohu the
little tiger has roared into life the
lpl continue their era of dominance and
they are leaving no one alive it's rng's
world and we're just living in it
what a performance from rng here across
the series so rng take the series they
become msi champions again and it
clearly shows that riot had the right
idea making sure that this team was able
to compete at this event but for xiaohu
it's a special moment he's now won three
msi titles in his career which is a
record and one that he shares with his
teammate ming
but notably xiaohu did it on two
different roles
in back to back
it's unprecedented the guy is writing
his own legend before our eyes right now
but the trophy presentation was less
than stellar obviously as rng were
literally sitting in a room in shanghai
instead of in the venue in busan and it
clearly wasn't the same as popping off
in front of a crowd and with the korean
home team taking home second place the
venue was also eerily quiet it doesn't
stop there though obviously there were
plenty of expectations for t1 and in a
post-match interview published by inven
global t1 general manager and coach polt
appeared to dump a lot of the
responsibility for the game 5 loss on
not having blue side now to be fair no
one's arguing that blue side isn't an
advantage in the draft being able to
pick that first champion just
fundamentally shapes the draft process
and it is important even at this
tournament msi 2022 you can see blue has
a several percentage point edge here but
rng was able to pick blue side first
because of their performance earlier in
the tournament and if you can't win
games on red side how are you gonna win
worlds now blue side did win every game
in this series and maybe poult truly
believes that had they played blue side
again the trend would have continued but
let's just be real here the draft that
we got in game 5 can't be completely
excused
and after all this was a response to a
question about the draft if you're a t1
fan there's a lot to like here even
though they lost msi they still play
second and the roster seems to be
getting stronger instead of stagnating
or something the young players around
faker will benefit from this experience
when they inevitably attempt to make
their run at worlds now to the west if
you're an n a fan eg's run to the semis
is one of the most exciting runs by an n
a team in some time and even though they
did get smashed once they arrived at the
semis the team is young and absolutely
packed with talent getting there at all
is an accomplishment for real but if
anything the expectations are even
higher now eg's dany actually tweeted
about how the season can be pretty
jam-packed if you're you know winning so
hopefully they figure out a way to
balance it all and come back stronger
now g2 started strong in the rumble
stage going 4-0 with wins against teams
like rng and t1 but things kind of fell
apart from there they only won one of
their next five games and the slump
continued into the bracket stage where
t1 casually swept them aside 3-0 though
they had a rough finish i think a semi's
appearance for this team was important
hopefully they get some data about this
international competition and their
analysts and coaches can come away with
some answers for them the next time they
face off this msi was one of the most
interesting i can remember and
even at a tournament that can constantly
surprise you as a fan and a viewer
this one was weirder than normal sure
some things were maybe what you'd expect
a banger china versus korea final name
eu
going out in semis other things felt
very different like the eventual
champions playing from a practice room
in shanghai instead of at the venue
because of kovit or perhaps the
artificial ping that had to be
implemented to accommodate that
arrangement and finally faker and crew
who looked pretty much unstoppable
hitting a wall what did you guys think
for me i want to see the faker xiaohu
rematch at worlds and hey we all thought
this was the year of t1 maybe this is
the year
of xiaohu just saying who knows right
let me know what you guys loved about
the tournament what you disliked what
you thought was weird in the comments
below i like to take a pass through and
see what you guys think every time i do
one of these videos we'll catch you next
time
i don't have any hot water tried to
shave but then i was like i will rip
apart my face with a razor if i use cold
water so i didn't do that i just got in
the shower and i just screamed
throughout the entire shower and then i
came downstairs and looked at myself in
the camera and i'm like wow hi
the facial hair is not really working
but i can't like would you rather have
this or would you rather have my face
look like it was carpet bombed by one of
the great powers of world war one like
no i had to do what i had to do